one porter here's a shot from 17  finally gets one to drop he's one of  eight  sometimes that's all it takes seed the  ball go through the rim let's see if  that can  get porter junior going offensively here  because they need that secondary score  for this nugget team  porter was watching on the distance  rivers was leaning in on the switch  and booker drains it this young man has  zero fear and i'm telling you this is  very reminiscent  of his childhood idol kobe bryant how  many times did we see kobe make a move  like this pump fake  jab step the defender crowds you and you  just raise up with contact  and be able to knock down an 18-footer  10-7  so far for booker he's got the words of  kobe tattooed